اعتبر تتوي وزاره البيئه والمياه والزراعه
السعوديه الخطه التوسعيه لزياده الانتاج
الزراعي في البيوت المحميه باجماليه
استثمارات تبلغ اربعه مليارات ريال حتى
لعام 2025 تادف الخطه الى رفع الطاقه
الانتاجيه عبر تشجيع استخدام التقنيات
الحديثه في القطاع الزراعي
وتسهم في انتاجيه اضافيه تقدر ب 430,000
طن لتصل الى الطاقه الانتاجيه الاجماليه
للبيوت المحميه الى ما يزيد عن مليون طن
سنوي
تفاصيل الاكثر حول هذه الخطه لزراعه
المحميات في السعوديه مع الزميله العنود
العبدلي
قبل اكثر من ثلاثه عقود تغيرت طرق الزراعه
والفلاحه في السعوديه هذا تطوير مشاهدينا
لم يتوقف حيث اعتمدت وزاره البيئه والمياه
والزراعه مؤخرا الخطه التوسعيه لزياده
لانتاج الزراعي في البيوت المحميه وذلك
باجمال استثمارات تبلغ 4 مليارات ريال حتى
العام 20 خمسه وعشرين وذلك بهدف رفع
الطاقه الانتاجيه عبر تشجيع استخدام
التقنيات الحديثه في قطاع الزراعي وزير
البيئه السعوديه المهندس عبد الرحمن
الفضلي اكد ان الخطه توسعيه فتسهم في
انتاجيه اضافيه تقدره باربعه 130.000 طن
لتصل لتصل الطاقه الانتاجيه اجماليه
للبيوت المحميه الى ما يزيد عن مليون طن
من سنوات مشاهدينا ماذا عن الدعم المقدم
للمزارعين في السعوديه خلال عام المنصرم
20 22 نحو خمسه مليارات ريال قدمها صندوق
نيه الزراعيه على شكل قروض للقطاعات
الزراعيه الانتاجيه ومنها البيوت المحميه
احدى القطاعات الرئيسيه التي مورها
الصندوق ميزات عديده لزراعه في البيوت
المحميه التي تشهد تطورا ملحوظا في كل
مجالاتها التقنيه والانتاجيه والوقائيه
ومن هذه الميزات مشاهدينا انتاج المحاصيل
في غير المواعدها واطاله مواسم توفرها كما
تعد عاملا رئيسا لنجاح الانتاج الزراعي
المتخصص كزراعه العضويه وتوفر الحمايه في
تامين تاثيرات الظروف المناخيه المختلفه
اضافه الى ان استخدام التقنيات الحديثه في
القطاع الزراعي والبيوت المحميه اسهما في
توفير المياه الراي بالنسبه تصل الى 60 في
المئه وفقا لنتائج البحوث والدراسات
العلميه التي نفذتها وزاره البيئه في
السعوديه
معنى عبد العظيم وكيل وزاره البيئه
والمياه والزراعه لشؤون الزراعه المهندس
احمد العياده مهندس احمد مرحبا بك اولا ما
هي اهم مرتكزات هذه الخطه التوسعيه في
البيوت المحميه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اكثر من 4 مليار ريال ريال المساهمه في
تعزيز الامن الغذائي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ما يخص قطاع الخبر
بدانا في وضع القطط
الاعلام عن هذه
الاستثمارات اا منذ عام 2017 وتستطيع ان
ارد بعض الارقام
من عام 2017 كنا في حدود 250,000
سنخرج ان شاء الله على مشارف ال25/11 اكثر
من مليون هذا يعتبر من الاسرع نمو في
العالم للبيوت المحميه وذلك الاهداف عديده
بتعمل الوزاره عليها ومن ضمنها الاستدامه
المائيه وكذلك الاستفاده من الموارد
المتاحه لدينا لدينا خطه واضحه كذلك ضمن
هذه الخطه من ضمن مكونات الخطه اننا نصدر
بعض انواع الخضار في الدول الاوروبيه
خصوصا في مواسم الشتاء التي لا
تتوفر لدى الدول الاوروبيه امكانيه
المتاحه لانتاج هذه الفضاء حتى تساهم ان
شاء الله في الميزان التجاري للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه على خلق الوظائف في مثل
هذا القطاع الذي يناسب
ابناءنا وبناتنا المواطنين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ما هو حجم مشاركه القط
الخاص في هذا المجال
لمده ثلاث سنوات القادمه 4 مليار 400 ريال
هيقرض الصندوق التلميذ الزراعي من 30 الى
40% ااا يلاحظ كذلك البارد كبير من
الشركات الزراعيه المدرجه في سوق المال
السعودي على وتن على دخول شركات جديده في
هذا المجال
وان نحن نعمل معهم جنبا على جنب
الاستثمارات هذه المؤكده باذن الله ووضعنا
الحته الادنى لها اربع مليار ريال لكن همم
نعتقد انها ستصل باذن الله الى 4 مليار
و500 مليون في حدود 2015 مثل هذه
الاستراتيجيه ولا هذه الخطه الى اي ماده
بالفعل يمكن ان تحقق الامن الغذاء الوطني
وفي اي المنتجات يعني ماذا تستهدفون
تحديدا
نستهدف الاساس الخضار المطلوبه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من ضمنها الطماطم
والخيار والكذلك جميع انواع الخضار وهذه
الانواع الحمل وصلنا الى بعض المستهدفات
الى 100% والجزء الاخر الان
ارسلتوا فيها
المياه
الخيار
انت عارف بلد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لكن هناك فرصه كبيره للتصدير في مجال
البيوت المحميه للتقنيات الحديثيه الحديثه
المتقدمه وبدانا ولله الحمد الان نصل الى
بعض الدول ولكن المستهدفه نقل كبير ايران
وضخمه جدا في الوصول في الدول المستهدفه
في الدول الاتحاد الوطني
تكلمت انه انتم كذلك من خطتكم تصدير
الخضار لبعض الدول
الاوروبيه مثلا في فصل الشتاء انواع
الخضار ايضا تستهدفونها في هذه الخطه
لتصدير الى هذه الدول
الشركه بعض انواع
الطماطم اللي ذات يعني القيمه العاليه
وكذلك بعض انواع الخيار ذات مع العاليه
والفلفل ده تقديم العالي والان الحمد لله
نعمل احنا مع الجانب الهولندي وضعنا بعض
ورشه العمل بين ال- همم المنتجين
السعوديين وبعض المستوردين من همم من
هولندا ونتوقع ان شاء الله انها تبدا
نشاطات تلك تلك الخطه بمشيئه الرحمن خلال
السنه القادمه هذه السنه والسنه
هذا ايضا الى اي همم حد يمكن ان يزيد من
مساهمه المحتوى المحلي كمستهدف لهذه الخطه
وكم حجم فرص العمل المتوقعه او المستهدف
همم مهندس احمد
فرص العمل لا يحضرني الرقم الان بالنسبه
للخطه بالكامل لكن من اهم
من اهم من اهم مرتكزات القطه
لدينا مركز وطني للزراعه ما يسمى باستدعمه
حيث توائم مع هذه الخطه في وضع
انشاء اكاديميه متخصصه في مجال البيوت
المحميه
تستطيع العاملين في هذا المجال
والمستوقع تخرجهم من كليه الزراعه وبعض
المعاهد المتخصصه للوصول الى تهيئه
التفاصيل ان شاء الله شكرا لك وكيل وزاره
البيئه والمياه والزراعه لشؤون الزراعه
المهندس احمد العياده